I'm declaring it's Taco Tuesday I never
actually hear what's gonna happen before
it happens and they're the greatest men
on the planet I could go on about why I
love tacos but here are just a few
reasons
tacos are versatile okay just the other
day we made sushi tacos here on the show
and it sounds weird but you know what
don't hate on it try it not too long ago
we made cocoa puffs and fruity pebble
tacos that's like a sugar express taco
which hi yes yeah I mean you might die
but it's good it's fine Plus tacos are
the cutest food to dress the baby come
on is that the sour cream yeah it looks
like whipped cream which let's make
those tacos I love whipped cream okay
tacos are also the reason I have a very
special guest sitting in my audience
will my special guest please stand up
[Applause]
well the real Danny Trejo please stand
up please do so what does your shirt say
don't be negative eat taco
[Applause]
Breaking Bad but in LA you're also known
for tacos tell us about try post tacos
well first of all we've got seven
restaurants one doughnut shop and we
even have a restaurant with right in the
airport next to the puck guy that puck
guy that guy well I told everyone you
know when I love about tacos why do you
love tacos why did you start you know
what first of all tacos are versatile
secondly children with autism don't do
well with gluten yeah so we got
gluten-free tacos and we have vegetarian
vegan gluten turn into the first one
[Laughter]
I love it you brought some tacos today
right for it
[Applause]
okay oh my gosh okay I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
YouTube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this